Marvel Studios has confirmed that the
X-Men are coming we have now entered the
part of the Multiverse Saga where the
X-Men are about to be a huge part of the
MCU moving forward and right now Marvel
Studios is very aware that we know the
X-Men are coming and now they are
starting to tease them and some of you
may have seen this but in the latest
promo that they gave us for the Marvels
they actually teased this check it out
Captain
Marvel there's a different reality
bleeding into
ours they're
[Music]
here the Marvel get tickets now so did
you catch that little Xmen there first
of all Monica Rambo says that there are
different realities bleeding into theirs
which is obviously about incursions an
incursion is happening in the Marvels
this is confirmed but if you notice the
words on the screen it says be there for
what comes next and when the words come
next start to disappear from the screen
when they start to fade away the X in
next stays highlighted teasing us of
what exactly is going to come next in
the MCU Plus in the actual film for the
Marvel's we are going to see an X-Men
Cameo this has now been confirmed by
Marvel themselves with this trailer and
the best part is we pretty much know
what the trajectory of the mutants in
the MCU is going to be like up until
Secret Wars and then after we've gotten
a lot of info about the Marvels about
the Thunderbolts Deadpool 3 secret Wars
and even Captain America Brave New World
could possibly hint at the Weapon X
Program being developed so if you are
ready for the mutant and X-Men Saga to
begin Marvel Studios has just teased
that it has begun what is up everybody
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things Marvel and MCU I'm
your host Warren Thompson and today
we'll break down what exactly is going
to happen with the X-Men in the MCU
moving forward in the Multiverse Saga
and then after quick reminder we did
start a new monthly giveaway for the
month of November for a chance to win a
PS5 and Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items all you
have to do is subscribe and leave a
comment on each of our videos we pick a
random winner at the end of each month
and the winner gets to choose one item
and big congratulations to last month's
winner this YouTube user at user- MX
plus a lot of other numbers and letters
we've already been in contact so
congrats to John pipia Jr for being the
winner for the month of October so the
big xt's is very appropriate for the
Marvels there is going to be an X-Men
cameo in the Marvel's post credit scene
that was a recent report going around
and it seems like Marvel Studios just
confirmed this themselves plus not to
mention they did confirm Kamala Khan to
be a mutant in Miss Marvel and when they
confirmed this mutation that she has the
X-men theme even played in the
background so it looks like this might
be further explored a little bit at
least in the Marvels now as far as the
post credit scene is concerned Monica
actually kind of talked about it in this
promo when she said a reality was
bleeding into theirs that's an incursion
and we know that at the end of the movie
they're going to be dealing with an
incursion and from what we understand
and believe a character is going to end
up in another universe and an X-Men is
going to greet them this is going to be
the tie between the fox universe and the
main MCU and this is going to lead us
directly into Deadpool 3 so the
post-credit scene for the Marvels is the
first step in Marvel Studios bringing us
the old Fox X-Men Legacy characters into
the MCU that's just going to be a little
bit of a tease but we get the full thing
in Deadpool 3 if you've been keeping up
with the news you know a lot of old Fox
X-Men characters are going to be
returning for Deadpool 3 Deadpool 3 from
what we understand right now is
basically what we hoped Multiverse of
Madness is going to be it sounds like
both Deadpool himself and the TVA are
going to be going to a bunch of
different universes where we are going
to see a lot of different variants of a
lot of different characters and I'm sure
they'll be some really cool surprises
and cameos thrown in but for the most
part we know we are going to be seeing a
lot of the old Fox X-Men characters and
director Sean Levy even confirmed this
he said they're not going to ignore the
legacy of fox of that X-Men universe
that fox created plus you have actors
like Patrick Stewart who after
Multiverse of Madness came in and said
yes you know what me and Ian McKellen
we're not done yet we're going to
reprise our role so he pretty much
spoiled that a little bit ago so
Deadpool 3 is when Marvel Studios is
just going to go full out in bringing
all of these old Fox characters to the
MCU putting in one place via the TVA
with our regular MCU characters and
other variants from what we understand
they're going to build a pretty big
multiversal army consisting of a lot of
different Heroes and then that will lead
into Secret Wars which is the final part
of Kevin Fig's plan to honor the old Fox
X-Men characters and then bring in the
next part of the new Mutant X-Men
characters which has already begun in
the MCU as we mentioned with Kamala Khan
and as they called him in the movie NE
more so what is Marvel Studios plan to
bring a new X-Men characters to the MCU
before Avengers Secret Wars ends we'll
talk about that in just a bit but first
big thank you to fume for sponsoring
this video fume is a GameChanger for a
lot of people in turning bad habits into
good habits a lot of people struggle
with these bad habits but fume looks at
these in a different way not everything
in the habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit and
that's exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trif nume.com and use code
Cosmic to save temp % off when you get
the journey pack today that's TR
f.com and use code Cosmic to save an
additional 10% off your order today now
obviously with the tease of X-Men coming
in the Marvels they don't just mean the
fox X-Men characters although don't get
me wrong that is indeed one of the
things that they do mean a fox X-Men
character is showing up in the post
credit but like I said Kamala con is
also a mutant they confirm this and they
are indeed going to continue to
introduce new Mutant type characters in
the MCU up until Secret Wars this is
going to start to be severely hinted at
with the Thunderbolts and some of you
may know why in the Thunderbolts movie
we know that they're going to go to what
is now going to be called tyut Island in
the movie The eternals the celestial
tyut got turned into stone and now it
resides in the ocean with some of it
sticking out this is tyut Island and
apparently what it's made of is
adamantium and of course many of us know
that metal to be what Wolverine's Claws
and the rest of the metal that he has in
his body is is made out of and this is
our first step of teasing our new
Wolverine in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this right now is confirmed to
be happening in the Thunderbolt so one
thing that is not yet confirmed to be
happening before this could be in
Captain America Brave New World where
Thunderbolt Ross could be trying to
essentially create a weapon x program
this is why the conflict comes in the
first place in Captain America Brave New
World Thunderbolt Ross is still
experimenting with super soldier serum
he's still trying to create super
soldiers because he wants what he's
always wanted he wants to be able to
control the superhero team that is what
the sovia Accords were really about now
we've learned that the sovia chords are
no longer in effect however I'm sure
Thunderbolt Ross does not like that and
if he had his way they would still be in
effect because again he wants to control
them but I think after Brave New World
he's going to realize that he's never
going to truly be able to control an
Avengers team so he'll probably try to
create his own enter the weapon x/ super
soldier program him trying to gentically
create superheroes that he could control
so that they could do his bidding his
dirty work if this does indeed happen
this will be our first teas towards
webon X and Wolverine in the MCU the new
Wolverine that is but if not we'll get
our teas in the Thunderbolts and then of
course everything will build up to
Avengers Secret Wars where we are going
to see both Fox X-Men but also new X-Men
that we have not seen before new X-Men
played by actors we have never seen so
it'll be a combination of the old X-Men
plus new X-Men but then after Secret
Wars we know that essentially Marvel
Studios is doing a soft reboot and then
moving forward from what we've been told
there will be no more old Fox X-Men
Legacy characters but just the New
Mutants moving forward and that is
primarily what the new saga is going to
be about even the Avengers are kind of
going to take a little bit of a back
seat while the X-Men and the Fantastic 4
take the spotlight so moving forward
with the X-Men in the MCU it is
primarily going to be about these old
Fox X-Men characters however Marvel
Studios is also going to start teasing
the new X-Men this is a part of their
plan because they know that some people
are kind of bored with Marvel right now
in fact the whole reason that they
changed the post credit scene for the
Marvels is so people go and see it so
they get excited because right now the
numbers for the Marvels are not looking
really good so they are enticing people
now with an X-Men tease which honestly
is very enticing we all want to go see
it now because of this X-Men Cameo but
it's primarily going to be about the old
X-Men and the Multiverse Saga will say
goodbye to them properly it'll be Kevin
fy's farewell to them and then we'll
start off in the new saga which we
believe is going to be the mutant Saga
with all of these new X-Men characters
hopefully they'll be built up like The
Avengers were and then we'll get a full
X-Men movie but we'll have to wait and
see on that in the meantime let us know
what you think about Marvel studios's
plan for the X-Men in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest news you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof